Uh,
this is always something I've been
interested for,
something that I've,
I've,
I've wanted to enrich myself with.
I think a lot of people,
you're,
you're a busy guy as far as I can tell.
You do speaking engagements,
lectures,
you operate a youtube channel.
Presumably you're a voracious reader.
I saw you on the couch.
He had a book open yet,
like a moment you're reading and you're
a prolific tweeter.
You tweet a lot.
So my question is how do you tweak your
approach?
How do you organize your time?
How do you remain focused and productive
in the face of insurmountable at work
lists?
Schedules and I have help.
I mean my wife in particular in the last
year has been unbelievably helpful.
I mean it's become a full time job for
her really helping me manage my schedule
and keep me on track.
But a lot of it is like I get up in the
morning,
I have like everything scheduled.
I know exactly what I'm supposed to do.
There's a hierarchy of,
of law,
of priority and I'm really operating on
a day to day level right now because
there's so many things to do.
I can't look more than about a day or
two ahead,
although it's,
it's,
it's basically scheduled now,
but I learned to discipline myself when
I was in graduate school when I was
writing,
I wrote a book called maps of meaning
that was published in 1999 and I've
worked for that on that for about 15
years,
about three hours a day and I really
sort of grabbed myself by the scruff of
the neck and forced myself to learn how
to concentrate without,
without deviation.
How do you do that?
How do you,
how do you focus that intensely?
Because I,
I often have trouble,
like I get overwhelmed sometimes when I
have a lot of work and the,
the worst feeling is like when I feel
like I have a ton of work and I do work
all day,
but I still feel like I didn't get
anything done.
Yeah.
But all the time you probably did
probably conscientious person.
Do you know?
I don't even know what exactly that
means.
Well,
okay.
So that's another thing we could mention
briefly.
I have a website called understand
myself.com
and I set up a coupon code for your
viewers.
So it's h three,
h three o what's the understand
myself.com.
And you can go there and take a
personality test that was devised in my
lab.
The main researcher was Dr Colin de
Young who is now a professor at the
University of Minnesota,
but we took the standard big five trait
model,
which is the standard modern personality
model.
So that's extroversion,
which is a positive emotion dimension
and extroverted people are enthusiastic
and assertive.
So you're both enthusiastic year.
Really assertive.
That would be my.
I can be.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you wouldn't be doing this sort of
thing.
I'll put an extra shirt.
So because you know,
you're,
you're verbally fluent and,
and um,
you'd like to engage in that sort of
thing.
Um,
so that's a positive emotion dimension.
It's associated with the positive
emotion that you feel when you're moving
towards desired things.
Um,
and the next dimension is sometimes it's
called neuroticism,
and sometimes negative emotionality.
Well,
people who are high in neuroticism are,
have some anticipatory anxiety.
Um,
you know,
you have anticipatory anxiety if you're
worried about going somewhere and it
really bugs you and then you get there
and like 20 minutes later you're calm
and it's okay.
Big Time,
big time.